I think
as people are coming in,
grab a seat so we can get started.
It's really my pleasure to help chair this
last part four of four of our Chemistry to
Clinic educational session
today. And this session will focus on
the concept from transcript to protein and how
taking new frontiers into drug discovery.
Just to briefly
get us going here, I thought we would have a...
Okay, we may be working or may not be.
Just to give you a brief introduction here, so what you're going to hear,
we have three speakers today, and we're going to hear about how
leveraging mechanisms of induced
proximity in three different ways can allow us
to get at challenging drug targets.
And we're going to hear about modulating
factors
such as
transcription and chromatin-modifying factors to alter gene
expression. I think we hear a little bit of that from our first speaker,
Dan Nomura.
Then we're going to hear some exciting
data coming from Halod Therapeutics and J&J on
their Rip-Tag platform, which is
really exciting. And then I'll
end by telling you a little bit about targeted protein degradation.
So I'll hand the podium over to our first speaker, Dan
Nomura.
Thank you so much for inviting me to give a talk here, and I'm excited to
give update on our latest work.
Uh-oh.
Oh, boy. Okay. So
our lab is really interested in going after the undruggable proteome.
And I think this is still one of the biggest bottlenecks that we face in modern
drug discovery. That's still over 90% of proteins are considered
undruggable, and these include things like protein complexes or intrinsically
disordered proteins, where it's really unclear where within these smooth interfaces
or unstructured proteins like this, we can identify a tractable binding
pocket that we can pharmacologically interrogate.
And I would argue that, this is just my selfish opinion, that among all the
different kind of undruggable classes of proteins, transcription factors are
probably one of the least druggable class, yet still one of the highest value
classes of targets in human disease.
And that's because transcription factors also belong to protein complexes or
protein DNA complexes, and they also tend to have very high levels of
intrinsic disorder. Yet we've known, for example, in cancer, of so
many major drivers of cancer that are transcription factors, including
things like MYC and beta-catenin and ERB7 and NERF2.
Oh, I guess the pointer is not working either.
And also inflammatory transcription factors like IRF5.
And these just represent the tip of the iceberg of tens of thousands of other
protein targets like this. And so our premise has always been that if we can
identify ligandable sites across all proteins in the proteome, that would really
allow us to go after drugging anything that we want.
And so to do that, we've been utilizing chemical proteomics and coupling that with
covalent ligand discovery platforms to both discover ligandable sites and ligand
those sites directly in complex biological systems.
We've also been using this to expand the scope of targeted protein degradation, and
I'll just very quickly allude to work that we've done in that space.
And I'll focus much of my time today towards the last
two-thirds of my talk on developing new induced proximity-based therapeutic
modalities beyond degradation, enabled by chemoproteomic approaches as well.
All towards discovering new therapeutics and also the complementary arsenal of
therapeutic modalities that allow us to go after tackling intractable
targets. And so, having come out of Ben Cravatt's lab at Scripps many
years ago, the underlying chemoproteomic approach that we use is activity-based
protein profiling or ABPP, that uses reactivity-based chemical probes to
profile proteome-wide reactive functional ligandable sites directly in complex
biological systems. And using these reactivity-based probes and chemoproteomic
approaches, we've now identified upwards of over 100,000 potential ligandable
sites across really the vast majority of the human proteome at this point.
And we've also generated large libraries of elaborated
electrophiles that we can then use to screen against these
proteins, either recombinant proteins or directly in complex biological systems,
to enable the discovery of more selective ligands against specific ligandable sites
on specific targets. And you can then use the chemoproteomic approaches to assess
things like target engagement, target identification, and also proteome-wide
selectivity. So you can couple that with medicinal chemistry efforts to not only
optimize potency but also proteome-wide selectivity of your molecule as well.
And so,
as it relates to the field of targeted protein degradation,
there have been several still major bottlenecks, right?
If you have an undruggable target, finding that black ball part is still really
challenging in your herobifunctional andWhile there are over 600 E3 ligases,
we still only really have E3 ligase recruiters for a relatively
small number of them. And that's because E3 ligases are also quite challenging to
target as well, although I think Ryan has now targeted dozens at this
point.
And as it relates to molecular gludegraders, outside of the IMID class
of molecules,
most molecular gludegraders so far have been either accidentally discovered or
found through phenotypic screens.
And it's been quite challenging to develop molecular gludegraders in a
target-centric manner in a rational way.
And so these have been relatively large bottlenecks in the field in
realizing the full potential of targeted protein degradation.
As relates to how we've expanded on this, for example, discovering new E3 ligase
recruiters, we've used covalent chemoproteomic approaches to first, for example,
identify this covalent electrophilic natural product nimbolide as an
RNF14 recruiter for PROTACs. We subsequently developed
an RNF4 recruiter. In collaboration with Michael Rappa's group, we developed a
FEM1B recruiter. We've also developed recruiters against E2 ubiquitin
conjugating enzymes like UBE2D, as well as cullin adapter
proteins like DDB1 for cull four and SKP1 for cull one
adapter proteins. And as it relates to the rational design of molecular
gludegraders, we've also taken a chemistry-centric approach, and I'll
touch on this later on in non-degradative glues that I'll talk about
later. But we've taken a chemistry-centric approach where we've started
with well-defined protein targeting ligands and then elaborated a
variety of electrophilic handles off of the exit vector to identify
permissive covalent degradative handles and also complementary
permissive E3 ligase pairs for the rational design of these
small monovalent degraders. And so, for example, we've identified a
fumarate-based handle that targets a quality control E3 ligase,
RNF126. And subsequently, we've also identified two
different covalent small handles that are highly transplantable
across a number of different protein targeting ligands to convert these otherwise
non-degradative molecules into molecular gludegraders of their targets.
In this case, we're targeting two different unique cysteines, either cysteine
119 on DCAP16 with the vinyl sulfonyl piperazines, or
cysteine 173 and 178 with the fumaramide scaffold
that I show on the right. And we've identified ligandable sites
really across the vast majority of most of the components of the ubiquitin
proteasome machinery, and so we can systematically keep doing this over and over
again.
But what about all these major drivers of cancer that I've been alluding to, right?
Of which only a small fraction of them have any kind of small molecule associated
with them, because most of these cancer drivers that we know of belong to these
really intractable classes of targets.
But if you mine our ligandability database, we've identified ligandable sites
across the vast majority of these cancer drivers.
So what about transcription factors like MYC, which I don't have to introduce to
this cancer audience. But in our database, while MYC
has been very, very intractable to direct drug discovery approaches because it's
highly intrinsically disordered, right, and this is just an AlphaFold approximation
of what MYC looks like. But in our database, we had identified cysteine
203 as a particularly aberrantly reactive cysteine within MYC in an
intrinsically disordered region of MYC.
Now, usually targeting IDR regions in transcription factors is thought to be
impossible because there's no presumed structure there.
But something was conferring some kind of hyperreactivity to that particular
cysteine. So we thought maybe there's some kind of transient pocket that's
being formed among an ensemble of different conformations that it's
taking that we can potentially covalently and kinetically trap in
order to inhibit MYC function. And so, to
help address this and also to help give us more confidence on the progressibility
of a molecule that comes out of something like this, where
one of the things that we had previously been able to do is identify a covalent
molecule that binds to a cysteine on MYC.
But we weren't sure whether that binding was in a purely reactivity-driven manner
or whether there was some kind of transient binding pocket that we were recognizing
with molecular recognition. And that's a pretty big distinction because from a med
chem perspective,
if there's really no pocket there and your molecule's just reacting with that
cysteine in a purely reactivity-driven manner,
it's going to be hard to drive down potency based on some kind of affinity-driven
interaction. And so to address this, we went back to the drawing board on
warhead design, and we really thought about tempering back the reactivity of our
cysteine-reactive warheads with these sulfonyl zeradines, which are barely reactive
with the glutathione and cysteine.
And we've also embedded in stereochemistry directly into the warhead.
And so the premise was, could we actually stereoselectively
engage an intrinsically disordered cysteine on MYC?
Because that would really indicate that there must have been some kind of transient
binding pocket that we were recognizing, right, in a stereoselective manner, which
would give us again, more confidence into the progressibility of a molecule that
we'd find. And so we generated a library of molecules based on the sulfonyl
zeradine oxindole scaffold, and we screened them, in this case, in a high
bit screen to look for MYC degraders.
And through that, we identified this 236 molecule that was able to dose
responsively degrade MYC, but basically almost completely
inactive diastereomer 419. And you can see that on the right with Western
blotting that MYC levels are going down, and you can rescue that with a proteasome
inhibitor with their active molecule, but the inactive molecule doesn't lower MYC
protein levels.
Now, you might imagine that MYC in cells engages in a whole diversity of
different protein interactions.
So maybe we're creating a pocket in cells with different protein interactions.
But in collaboration with Novartis, they were able to actually purify
full-length human MYC-MAX protein.
And even with MYC-MAX-like protein as pure protein in a test
tube, we still see stereoselective engagement of MYC with our active molecule and
less so with our inactive molecule.
We also see certainly with cellular engagement in pull-down assays, since these
have alkaline probes on them, we can just treat cells and do a biotin click and
pull capture MYC. And we see stereoselective engagement of MYC.
By covalent chemoproteomic approaches and pull down proteomic approaches, we see
highly
robust engagement of MYC, although this original hit molecule has over 100 off
targets, so that's quite promiscuous still.
And then when we do a thermal stability assay on MYC in cells, what we find is that
instead of stabilizing MYC thermal stability, which is what usually happens when a
molecule binds to a protein, we actually see a significant destabilization of
MYC. In fact, we think that this is the mechanism through which we're degrading
MYC, through destabilizing the conformational ensembles of
MYC.This molecule, when we mapped its site of reactivity,
as expected, reacted primarily with cysteine 203, which we had predicted to be
the aberrantly reactive cysteine within MYC.
But what was quite interesting was that we quickly found that
not only in MYC, but if you look at how this molecule reacts across all of its
off-targets, in almost every single situation, there is an aspartic acid or
glutamic acid two positions over from the cysteine we were modifying.
That's certainly not a sequence preference of, for example, pan-cysteine probes
like iodoacetamide. And so we thought maybe that aspartic acid is helping
to coordinate the reactivity of that cysteine.
And consistent with that, you actually have to mutate both the cysteine and the
neighboring aspartic acid to get full rescue of MYC degradation.
So it seems like both of those amino acids are required for the reactivity of this
molecule.
This molecule is, in fact, functional.
We see nice dose-responsive inhibition of MYC transcription activity in cells with
the active molecule, but not the inactive molecule.
And by RNA-seq, we don't see just global
screwing up of transcription. We see quite selective manipulation of MYC
target genes in cells.
But one of the challenges with transcription factors, and I'll allude to this in
the next section of my talk, is that not only are transcription factors difficult
to ligand, but they also tend to have very fast turnover rates.
So that's a big challenge. And you can actually see with this molecule that
you see loss of MYC at two to four hours, but it's basically recovered by six hours
because MYC has such high turnover rates.
And so we had to do quite a bit of med chem on this to make a more
potent, but also more importantly, kinetically faster degrader that
can take out MYC to a much more deeper degree.
And through that, we were able to identify this 219A molecule that is, again, able
to dose responsively degrade MYC, and also 219B is a less active
diastereomer. We also see that not only with degradation, but also with
transcriptional inhibitory activity on the right.
And again, the mechanism is the same.
You have to mutate both the cysteine and the aspartic acid to get full rescue of
MYC degradation, but this molecule is now substantially more durable in its
action. We see now MYC degradation out to 24 hours as opposed to recovery by
six.
And by chemoproteomic approaches, this molecule still engages MYC, but with
far fewer off-targets now. Now, there are still a number of off-targets that still
have to be dialed out, but far fewer than the original hit molecule that I
showed you. And by global proteomics on the right, this molecule is exceptionally
selective at degrading MYC in cells with very few other proteins
changing. And so this has given us confidence that intrinsically
disordered regions, at least some of them, can actually be tackled with covalent
small molecules,
these IDR regions within transcription factors like MYC.
And subsequently, we've also been able to develop these covalent destabilizing
degraders. For example, against beta-catenin.
In collaboration with Amgen, we were able to develop one against AR and ARV7.
And in collaboration with Octant, we were able to develop a covalent
destabilizing degrader against the inflammatory transcription factors IRF5 and
IRF8.
But I alluded earlier again to the fact that transcription factors are really hard
to go after, not just because they're difficult to ligand, but also because they
have very fast turnover rate. So degradation may not even be the
best way to be able to disrupt transcription factors, because the cell will just
resynthesize the transcription factor quite rapidly.
Now, there are certainly ways to do this with a lot of the efforts that have gone
into epigenetic drug discovery. But many of those
epigenetic inhibitors, like dual EP300/CBP inhibitors or
SMARCA2/SMARCA4 inhibitors, because they manipulate the transcription of many
genes, their therapeutic window has been relatively limited.
So what you'd like to be able to do is do this in a loci-specific manner.
And there are ways to do this, for example, with epigenome editing, where you can
take a dCas9 with a guide RNA and fuse it to a DNA
methyltransferase to methylate specific genomic loci in a
site-specific manner. But these are 500 kilodalton protein complexes,
and are going to have major problems with systemic delivery.
And so can we do this with a completely small molecule-based approach?
And so that's what we've tried to do here with this transcriptional repression via
active chemical epigenetic reprogramming, or what we call TRACERS, where we've been
able to develop recruiters against transcriptional repression machinery that brings
in things like histone deacetylases as part of the nucleosome remodeling complex,
and then link those recruiters to transcription factor targeting ligands to now
recruit transcriptional repression complexes to specific genetic loci
to epigenetically silence and shut down transcriptional programming in
a loci-specific manner, and also with a completely, fully small molecule-based
approach.
And so out of patent literature, we were able to identify this
molecule that binds and inhibits this methyl binding protein,
MBD2. MBD2 usually
binds to CpG methylated oligo islands, DNA
islands, to bring in the nucleosome remodeling complex to deacetylate and shut
down transcription at specific genetic components.
And we wanted to further validate this molecule, and so we made a photoaffinity
alkyne functionalized probe version out of this, and we could show that compared to
the negative control, we can enrich out MBD2 out of cells.
And so it showed nice cellular target engagement.
We also, in collaboration with Novartis, were able to reconstitute the
nucleosome remodeling complex.
And while this molecule doesn't seem to bind to the individual components of
MBD2 or HDAC1 alone, when you put them together assembled in a
complex, you actually see now robust binding.
And so it seems like this molecule binds really only in the context of the full
complex, which certainly exists in cells, and so that's why we also capture it in
cells.So with that invalidation in hand, we then went after proof of
concept of this approach, initially going after the estrogen receptor just because
it's such a well-validated target in breast cancer and there's a lot of
pharmacology associated with it.
We took this estrone derivative, which is an ER agonist, as our ER targeting
ligand. And on the top here, while the MBD2 inhibitor or the
estrone ligand alone either stimulates or doesn't do anything to ER transcription
activity in breast cancer cells, when you now link these together in the
heterobifunctional molecule, we see now an over 90% suppression of
ER transcription activity in cells already at a high nanomolar concentration.
And this molecule turns out to be incredibly durable.
You can treat cells for just a few hours, wash out the compound, and transcription
stays inhibited for days afterwards.
And so it's an incredibly durable response.
To show you this is on-target activity, we could show a rescue of the
transcriptional inhibition with either excess of the MBD2 inhibitor or
with
competition
with a histone deacetylase inhibitor.
Indicating that, again, we're not sequestering ER away from its native
loci or disrupting ER protein complexes to inhibit ER transcription.
It actually requires the activity of HDAC being brought in through the
nucleosome remodeling complex to have that inhibitory activity.
And also to show
on-target mechanism of action, MBD2 knockdown also rescues this
transcriptional inhibitory activity that we see.
When we do RNA-seq, again, we're not just globally screwing up transcription, but
we're quite selectively
down-regulating ER target genes.
So we do a pathway analysis, ER pathways are the top pathways that are
disrupted. And when you knock down MBD2, you basically get a
transcriptionally silent signature.
So all the kind of global transcriptomic
profiles that we observe are really all driven through MBD2.
We've also done ATAC-seq to look at general chromatin accessibility to make sure
that we're not screwing up global chromatin accessibility.
And quite gratifyingly, we see that we're quite
selectively blunting ER loci
chromatin accessibility. Again, showing the selectivity of this molecule
manipulating ER target genes.
And so, that was a nice proof of concept, but there are already quite robust
ways to antagonize ER with things like fulvestrant and
other ER antagonists. So we wanted to go after more of a clinically
unmet need proof of concept, such as, for example, the truncation variant of the
androgen receptor, AR-V7, that drives androgen-independent prostate cancer
cells. And the reason why this is really undruggable is that AR-V7 is
basically missing the entire steroid-binding domain or ligand-binding domain that
AR antagonists like enzalutamide bind to.
And all that's left is a highly intrinsically disordered and now permanently
activated DNA binding and N-terminal domain.
But all of these prostate cancer cells still express full-length AR
alongside AR-V7. And so if you, for example, take
enzalutamide or, in this case, a selective androgen receptor modulator, in those
cells, you only get about a partial 40% inhibition of AR transcription
activity because the other 50% to 60% is driven by AR-V7.
But AR and AR-V7 are still binding to the same genetic loci.
So if you epigenetically shut down AR loci, you'll by default also shut down
AR-V7 loci as well. And so consistent with that now, when we take the
selective androgen receptor modulator on the left and then link it to the MBD2
recruiter on the right,
you get over a 90% suppression of AR transcription activity in
22RV1 androgen-independent prostate cancer cells that express both
AR and AR-V7. And you can rescue that again with an HDAC
inhibitor or with MBD2 knockdown.
And when you do RNA-seq, you see a global suppression of all the AR target genes,
much, much more so than you would observe with AR antagonists in these cells,
like enzalutamide, which again, only partially inhibits function.
And so we're quite excited about this approach to be able to now
epigenetically and loci specifically, and in a fully small molecule-based approach,
shut down specific transcriptional programming in a much more durable
manner than you might even get with a degrader type approach.
In the last few minutes, I also want to extend this to molecular glues.
Because the approach that I just showed you was with a heterobifunctional molecule,
which again, is larger molecular weight, has a heavier lift on med chem to make
it more drug-like. How do you do this with non-degradative molecular
glues? How do you rationally discover these types of things, especially as it
relates to transcription? And in my classrooms, I always give this
example of, for example, rapamycin that Jerry Crabtree and Stu
Schreiber discovered as a molecular glue between FKBP12 and mTOR.
And then 30 years later now, we have amazing programs from Revolution Medicines
developing pan-RAS inhibitors that acts through molecular glue
interactions with cyclophilin. But no medicinal chemistry biologist would have
thought, "I'm going to drug RAS by gluing it to this random protein cyclophilin,"
without the original discoveries from Stu Schreiber and Jerry Crabtree.
And so how do you do this against other targets while still allowing
for optimistic discoveries on the effector
side?And so we've taken the exact same strategies we've taken
for rational molecular glue degrader design, where we start with a protein
targeting ligand and then elaborate a variety of kind of electrophilic fragments
off of it to look, in this case now, not for degradation.
In fact, we specifically exclude degradation as an outcome, but rather for
neomorphic transcriptional activity downstream.
And so to show proof of concept of this in our first example,
we were really inspired by work coming out of Gerry Crabtree and Nathaniel Gray's
lab on these transcriptional epigenetic chemical inducers of
proximity, or TSIPs, where they were able to take a BRD4
inhibitor, JQ1, that brings a transcriptional activation BAF complex and link
it to a BCL6 inhibitor, where BCL6
is a transcriptional repressor.
And thereby, by bringing an activator to a transcriptional repressor, you
de-repressed BCL6 transcription, and that really potently killed cancer cells.
But in their paper, another thing that was really intriguing to me was they saw a
global suppression of MYC in addition to de-repression of BCL6,
indicating maybe this isn't just a simple on switch, but maybe it's actually
rewiring transcription. And so we wanted to further delve deeper
into that. And so we took a BCL6 inhibitor like they did,
and then instead of linking it in the hetero-bifunctional format, we just
elaborated a variety of electrophilic handles off of it without a linker.
And we specifically looked now for MYC downregulation more than what the
BCL6 inhibitor or the degrader could do alone.
And we were able to identify this molecule, this ZD186 molecule
that you see the BCL6 inhibitor in green and then the covalent
handle in blue that's presumably covalently attaching to something and gluing it
to BCL6. And by Western blotting, you could see that not only
BCL6 target genes like P21 are being de-repressed, but you also
see that downregulation of MYC. When you do a time course, you actually see that
MYC downregulation happens faster than P21 upregulation.
So these things are clearly kind of uncoupled, right?
And the MYC downregulation is actually happening first.
So we wanted to see what we were actually gluing to BCL6, and so we did a simple
BCL6 pull-down in the presence of our molecular glue, and we pulled out
BRD9, which biologically may not have been that interesting because
Nathaniel Gray was able to show with BRD4 that you could do this.
BRD9 is another bromodomain that brings a non-canonical
BAF activation complex. And so we were able to show that ternary
complex formation. We were also able to show that this reacts with an allosteric
cysteine 288 on BRD9. And this is, in fact, very
much the mechanism of this molecule.
You can show that the MYC downregulation and the P21
upregulation can be rescued with a BRD9 seven inhibitor, but not with a negative
control inhibitor. And if you knock out BRD9, you also get full
rescue of the MYC downregulation and P21 upregulation.
And by RNA-seq, once again, we see a global de-repression of
BCL6 target genes, but we also see a global suppression of
MYC genes as well. And so what we think is happening in this case
is on the left here, not only are we recruiting a transcriptional activation
complex by recruiting BRD9 to BCL6 loci to
de-repress BCL6. But BCL6 is a transcriptional repressor in
itself that can recruit things like the NCOR or SMART transcriptional repressing
complexes. And so we think that we're also recruiting those transcriptional
repression complexes, the oncogenic BRD9 loci, to shut down MYC
transcription as well. And we're now, through pull-down experiments, seeing these
transcriptional repression complexes also being recruited to BRD9
loci.
And in fact, this is just the tip of the iceberg of what we've been able to achieve
already. We've now taken other transcription factor targeting ligands,
extended using high-throughput chemistry and direct to biology approaches,
identified a whole bunch of new transcriptional
repressors, transcriptional activators, transcriptional rewiring agents, and
then through pull-down chemoproteomics experiments, identified new transcriptional
epigenetic effector proteins that we can use to manipulate and rewire
transcription in cancer cells in unique ways. All right.
So I'll end there. This is just the tip of the iceberg of what we're working on in
terms of covalent chemoproteomic approaches, and also expanding on targeted
protein degradation platforms. And I think, most compellingly, probably
the most exciting thing that we're working on is this new kind of induced proximity
approaches for manipulating transcriptional pathways,
especially in terms of rewiring them.
And it's just the tip of the iceberg what I showed you.
There are so many molecules we're finding that are uniquely rewiring
transcription in ways that you would not expect by bringing in
neomorphic protein complexes. So hopefully I'll be able to show you more of that
next year. And with that, I'll thank my lab at UC Berkeley.
Many of these projects were also done in collaboration with Novartis and also the
Mark Foundation for Cancer Research, and happy to take questions.
Please use the microphones in the room for questions.
Hi.
Is it on?
Very interesting talk. So your non-degraders,
so how do you think they work? They're not degrading, so
they're stabilizing. Do you think
they're messing up the actual dynamic regulation of the
complex, or are you trapping them in some sort of inactive
conformation? Are you talking about the BCL6 thing that I just showed now?
Yes.
Yeah. So
we're recruiting BRD9, which is a bromodomain that recruits a
transcriptional activation complex like the BAF complex, the non-canonical BAF
complex. And so
we're basically doing the same thing that Nathaniel Gray and Gerry Crabtree did
with TSIPs by recruiting a transcriptional activation complex to de-repress
BCL6, but doing so now with a molecular glue instead of a
hetero-bifunctional.
So do you have any idea how these glues changing the
conformation or complexes within the system?
We don't have a structure of it yet, but I imagine that we're not
changing the complex. We're just bringing in a new complex to
BCL6 to do this. Right? Yeah.
Hi, Nate Brooks. Great talk. You had previously shown that
you had Myc binders.
Uh-huh.
Have you tried to link the Myc binder with the BCL6 binder
to tether Myc and BCL6 together?
Right. Yeah, that's a really good question.
So,
we actually did think about that. I think we will be doing that.
Well, I'll get back to that in a sec.
So what we are doing is taking our Myc covalent binder and linking it to the MD2
recruiter to figure out whether we could get durable Myc transcriptional
repression.
And also, in that case, potentially dialing out the greater activity of the
molecule while still maintaining binding.
But yeah, we were also thinking, if you link a transcription
factor targeting ligand to BCL6, could
you potentially suppress the activity of that transcriptional loci
by bringing in the BCL6, but do so in a cell
type-specific manner? Because BCL6 is only expressed in B-cell lymphomas and
B cells. So could you
shut down transcription in a cell type-specific manner? Which would be really neat.
Yeah.
Right. Thanks.
Going back to the reactive cysteine in
Myc
and the fact that it's in a disordered
domain.
What do you think is happening here?
Are these small molecules stabilizing a
conformation here that would also occur naturally,
or is that really a de novo
conformation or de novo secondary structure that has no
physiological equivalent?
Right. So, I think this whole notion of intrinsic
disorder is probably
more complex than the name suggests.
I think these disordered regions are just very conformationally dynamic.
Maybe they're taking 100 different conformations, of which one of them is a
potential pocket that makes that cysteine hyperreactive.
And the nice thing about covalency is that you only have to see that transiently
very
frequently, and then it'll form a covalent bond, and then that's
it. It's an irreversible format. And so then maybe you select for
the less stable conformational ensembles that then make it more prone to
degradation. But based on 2D NMR studies, it's not like we're suddenly forming an
alpha helix. In fact, we're destabilizing the thermal stability of the protein.
So it's not stabilizing some complex or something.
We're actually destabilizing the protein that's leading to the degradation. Yeah.
All right. We've got time for one last quick question and answer.
Absolutely. Excellent work. Wow, he's tall.
So very cool. But playing devil's advocate on behalf of the cancer, for most
of these things, there's at least three and maybe four different things that need
to interact for this to have effect, which gives the cancer a lot of things that it
can potentially down-regulate to get away from this.
So it seems like combination approaches with maybe multiple of these would be
a pathway to sort of get around that.
So it takes too many things for it to get past.
But what are your thoughts as far as
resistance mechanisms?
Yeah, I think with any cancer medicine, you're going to eventually run into
resistance. But I would argue that compared to targeting something upstream in the
signaling pathways, where there's a number of different signaling pathways that
converge on the same transcription factor.
In fact, many of the resistance mutations that do happen from, for example, kinase
inhibitors, are still going through the same transcription factor downstream.
They just rewired another pathway or something downstream.
So, I would argue that a transcription factor might be harder to overcome,
like for example, taking out Myc, than something upstream of that in the kinase
pathway. But that's speculative.
Okay, great. Let's thank Dan again for a great talk.
Okay, up next we have Dr. Katherine Kaiser-Burkher, who will tell us about the
RIP-tag work from Halda Therapeutics and now J&J.
Thank you for the invitation to speak today, and it's wonderful to close out this
chemistry to clinic session. I have to say there's been
wonderful talks today and really an explosion in the induced
proximity field. So it's an incredibly exciting, innovative time in
induced proximity. And I even heard reference to RIP-tags earlier today in
HLD0915. So it's my pleasure to walk you through
the entire journey of the RIP-tag concept
all the way
from
conception to preclinical to the clinic.
And then
moving back and doing that with a second program.
So I'm going to share two programs with you today of this powerful new
modality to treat human disease.
So if you're not familiar with Halda, Halda is a company based in New Haven,
Connecticut. It was founded by Professor Craig Crews out of Yale University,
who's one of the pioneers in the induced proximity field, one of the original
inventors of PROTACs.
And we were really tasked with developing a new induced
proximity modality that took pharmacology beyond degradation.
So what can we use these heterobifunctional molecules to do to create
new pharmacology that would have an impact on human disease?
And that's where we invented RIP-tags, which stands for Regulated Induced
Proximity Targeting Chimera. And it's really this ternary
complex-driven pharmacology. And when I say ternary complex, I mean the
complex between the RIP-tag, a tumor-specific protein, and a
pan-essential protein. And it's really this pharmacology that
happens downstream of the ternary complex that has a profound effect in
oncology. And the RIP-tag binds a tumor-specific
protein. So you can think of that as the address for the tumor.
That's when it's going to drive our selectivity.
And then on the other end, it binds a pan-essential protein, which by definition is
essential for cell survival.And it's this ternary complex
formation and sequestration of the essential protein that results in
loss of function selectively of the essential protein in the tumor
cell and results in cancer selective cell death.
So it's truly a novel and unique mechanism of action that's driven
by the ternary complex that allows us to have this selective
tumor cell death independent of the underlying oncogenic driver, which
is a clear differentiation from traditional targeted therapy.
And it has activity across known mechanisms of resistance to standard
of care. And we see that both pre-clinically and now in the clinic.
I'm also proud to say that Halda was acquired at the end of last year, and we're
now part of a global organization with Johnson & Johnson, and we're
continuing to progress this platform within J&J.
Okay, so now I'm going to put a graphical depiction to the mechanism I just walked
you through. So on the right-hand side, we have a cartoon depiction of a
heterobifunctional molecule. I'm sure everyone in the audience is well familiar
with this. It's really just two ligands connected by a linker.
On the left-hand side, we have an orange triangle, which is a ligand for your
tumor-specific protein. And then on the right-hand side, you have a
ligand for an essential protein. Now, people have tried to drug essential
proteins for a long time in oncology.
I'm sure many of the people in this room have worked on essential protein
programs. But really, those have met with challenges of being
able to achieve suitable efficacy due to dose-limiting toxicity.
So this mechanism allows us to target those essential proteins
selectively in the tumor by leveraging the expression of the
tumor-specific protein and formation of the ternary complex.
So we call this a hold-and-kill mechanism.
The RIP-tag brings these two proteins together, and it forms a
neo-protein-protein interaction.
And it's this protein-protein interaction that really drives that
potent cell killing. And it drives the sequestration
and loss of function phenotype of the essential protein selectively in the
tumor. It's more than just inhibition of the essential protein.
It's truly the sequestration and loss of function, which results in
that cancer selective cell death.
Now, I described the mechanism to you on the last couple slides, but
since this is an educational session, I wanted to move out to a higher level.
We've heard a lot of talks today about
ternary complex, induced proximity, transcriptional rewiring.
And so I just want to talk a little bit about this globally and how we think about
it in the field of induced proximity, and especially as we see this field
evolve and all sorts of new ideas and new applications coming
into play. So what are we trying to do here with this modality?
We're trying to have potent cell killing with a large therapeutic
index.
So as discovery scientists, we're looking to maximize
this overall safety window. And by that, I mean having potent
activity in target expressing tissues or tumors and having
weak activity in healthy or non-target expressing tissues.
Now, there's multiple things that can contribute to this overall
safety window. The first being what I just described, this
formation of the neo-protein-protein interaction.
Now, the RIP-tag's designed, again, to have this potent trimer
formation, and it's a little bit more akin to a molecular glue.
You're going to require that tumor-specific protein binding first
to create an enhanced binding to the essential protein.
So the molecule's designed to have very weak binary
interaction with the essential protein in healthy tissues, and that's what
drives that overall safety window.
This is the easiest thing to measure and optimize in a medicinal
chemistry effort.
You can see here in a recombinant essential protein inhibition assay
that this molecule, this generic RIP-tag here,
has a very weak binding to the essential protein.
And then when you add in that tumor-specific protein, you get a nice
positive cooperativity of greater than 60 with now
enhanced binding to that essential protein.
So really, this is a key feature of these molecules.
Now, another thing can happen is this transcriptional rewiring.
You can have novel gain-of-function.
You can have upregulation of tumor suppressor proteins, for
example. And this is going to be completely context-dependent.
We also presented a poster at AACR last year focused on P53
Y220C, where we showed molecules that had different
features, that had more features of this transcriptional rewiring and upregulation
of P53, and molecules that had more of a loss-of-function
phenotype. So you can think of this as a feature that you could optimize in your
medicinal chemistry design, depending on the overall profile you
want in the molecule.
And there can also be intra-tumor accumulation.
These ternary complexes are very strong. They're long-lived.
They clear slowly from the tumors.
And so you can have this tumor accumulation, which can also
benefit your overall safety and activity window.
Okay, so today, now that I've talked through the concept of RIP-tags, I'm going
to speak to two assets. First, the HLD0915,
which is an AR BRD4 RIP-tag in prostate cancer.
This molecule has a robust preclinical efficacy and safety
profile. Also, in the Phase 1 dose escalation, we were able
to demonstrate a safe and active drug in first-line plus
mCRPC. And now the Project Optimist expansion is
ongoing.
Also, a second molecule, which is HLD0117, which is an
ER BRD4 RIP-tag in breast cancer. This will
recapitulate a lot of the principles I'm going to show you with 915.
Preclinical data demonstrates activity in ER-dependent,
co-driven, and independent disease.
So we're really excited to move this molecule into Phase 1 in
ER positive, HER2 negative metastatic breast cancer, and this trial is now in
flight.
And then overall, we've been able to demonstrate this proof of platform, this
preclinical neo-PPI pharmacology, and demonstrate this across
numerous tumor-specific protein and essential protein pairs.
And we're continuing to develop a pipeline, both in oncology as well as
beyond oncology.Okay. So then we'll move on
now to the HLD0915 RIP-TAG. Here you can see a crystal
structure of a close analog showing this
protein-protein interaction between the AR ligand binding domain and
BRD4 BD1.
It's always nice as a medicinal chemist to
see these ternary complexes and really this expansive nature of this
neo-protein-protein interaction that we're able to create with this molecule,
and actually some nice protein movement as well as the
RIP-TAG is able to really induce this expansive
neo-protein-protein interaction.
Now, this molecule has a significant opportunity as an
oral small molecule therapy, and it has the opportunity to be
transformational in prostate cancer.
Prostate cancer affects one in eight men in the United States, and
what's known about this disease is as it progresses from
castrate-sensitive to castrate-resistant prostate
cancer, we know that there's increasing AR expression, but a decrease in
AR dependence. And there's a whole host of resistance mechanisms that have
been well documented in mCRPC that can either be on target or
off target. Now, the promise of the RIP-TAG was the idea
that we could drive this
tumor-specific cell killing, but across these mechanisms of resistance,
because the RIP-TAG only relies on AR expression and drives cell
killing through BRD4, thus expecting it to be efficacious
across these heterogeneous mechanisms of resistance.
So this is a differentiated modality compared to other agents.
Again, we only require full-length AR to be present.
It does not need to be a driver.
You'll see that it has potent in vivo efficacy with regressions in multiple models
of resistance and superior to standard of care.
And again, the Phase 1 demonstrates an active and safe drug.
And so the promise of this modality is really it has the power of a biologic of
having this potent, broad tumor effect, but in an
oral small molecule.
So when we look at the in vitro profile of this molecule, we can
demonstrate this pharmacology in a number of different cell lines.
Here I'm going to show you the VCAP cell line, which is an AR-amplified model.
You can see that we get a potent ternary complex here between
HLD0915, AR, and BRD4 with an EC50 of
two nanomolar. You can see that either ligand alone shows no effect, as
you would expect. And then this ternary complex activity
translates very nicely into anti-proliferative activity in the VCAP cell
line, now having a GI50 of three nanomolar.
Now, one of the things we wanted to document early on was, would
these ligand binding domain mutations have an effect on the
formation of this ternary complex?
And so we selectively expressed three different clinically relevant point
mutations in a cell line background, and we're pleased to see that all of them
have equipotent ternary complex formation to wild type, really
demonstrating that one amino acid change wasn't enough to affect the
ability to form a ternary complex.
Now when we move in vivo, first we want to look at the PK/PD.
And so we were able to develop the ternary complex in tumors, so we can lace
tumors, look at the ternary complex, and we see a nice
dose-dependent increase in ternary complex with different
doses of HLD0915. So a nice dose-dependent
effect. Now, this is the most proximal PD readout of this
mechanism. Now, downstream of that, we wanted to look at BRD4
loss of function. And so what was nice to see is that this
dose-dependent ternary complex correlates very nicely to a
dose-dependent change in BRD4 PD markers.
So you can see a nice dose-dependent decrease in cMyc and a nice
dose-dependent increase in Hexim1 and TIXSNIP.
Now, data not shown on the slide is that we also see a very
nice kinetic correlation, too, between the long-lived ternary
complex and BRD4 PD modulation.
Now, as we look towards moving this in vivo to look at efficacy, we looked at
multiple models of CRPC, so moving from the left to
the right, we have the more resistant
models on the left and in the middle, and then a more hormone-sensitive
reflective model on the right. So first, if you look at the castrate
VCAP model, this is AR amplified. It also has the
splice variant V7 and a
p53 tumor suppressor mutation. Because of this, it has low
sensitivity to enzalutamide, as you can see in green, and we see very
nice activity with HLD0915. Actually, eight out of these
mice are showing regressions.
Now if you move to the middle model, this one was quite exciting for us.
It was a LNCaP-95 model. This is a completely
androgen-independent model, so enzalutamide has no activity in
this model. And you can see that 915 shows very robust
regressions in this model, really highlighting the power of the technologies,
only needing to leverage AR expression, not AR signaling, to have an
effect.
And then lastly, we have the LNCaP model on the right, which is a
hormone-sensitive, enzalutamide-sensitive model.
And you can see here that we have equipotent activity to enzalutamide, giving
confidence that we could also move earlier in line.
So as we move into the Phase 1-2, we started
at a 25 milligram dose.
This is dosed once
a day orally in 21-day cycles. We immediately saw
nice activity at the 25 milligrams.
We dose escalated to 100 milligrams, and we actually even did a
minus one cohort at 12.5 milligrams, given the
activity seen at the other doses. You can see at this time, this was
presented at the Triple Meeting in October, and you can see with this data cut, we
had 31 patients dosed and 40 patients enrolled, with only
four discontinuations and everyone else continuing on trial.
You can also see highlighted on this swimmer's plot, the best
reduction in PSA, as shown in percent at the end of each line, as
well as the number of resist responses highlighted there, which I'll highlight
again on upcoming slides.So
what was nice to see is that we had PSA responses across all
doses and across heterogeneous adverse molecular features.
So with this technology, the hope was we wouldn't need any patient
selection markers, that we'd have broad activity regardless of the
genetic profile of patients, and that bore out when we move into the
phase one. So you can see in the boxes on the bottom of the slide, we have
activity in AR-amplified patients, which isn't a surprise, right?
We're leveraging AR expression. But we don't need AR amplification
for activity, so it's active in both amplified and non-amplified patients.
It's also active in the AR ligand binding domain
mutations, but again, not a requirement for activity.
And it has activity in patients with the ARV7 splice variant.
So it was incredibly exciting to see this kind of activity across these diverse
molecular features.
Also, it's worth noting that we see activity across tumor suppressor gene
mutations, some of which are listed there on the top of the slide, really
just highlighting this, the broad activity bore out in the way that we saw
pre-clinically.
So overall, this molecule was shown to be active and safe in this phase one
dose escalation. And if you look at the PSA50 and
PSA90 response rates for patients with at least two cycles of
therapy, you can see at the 50-milligram dose, we have a 70%
PSA50 and a 40% PSA90.
Also worth noting is at this time we had five patients with
resist measurable disease, and all five of these patients had
PRs. We also had an additional patient with soft tissue
resolution. So really showing this profound reduction in
lesions, which was incredibly exciting to see.
And again, activity across these different genetic alterations.
So this encouraging activity and safety profile is
a proof of concept for RIPTacs in other tumor types as well.
And we're very excited about the development of this molecule as it continues in
phase two.
So with that, I'll go to the next section, which is
HLD0117, which is an ER
BRD4 RIPTAC. So it binds the ER ligand binding
domain and BRD4. Here is a close analog of
117 in a crystal structure, again, highlighting the expansive
nature of this protein-protein interaction.
Also, you see here highlighted helix 12, which actually has a
very different conformation than's ever been seen in
previous structures of ER. And we saw similar things with this helix in
the AR program as well. So really highlighting that these proteins
can have significant movements as you're inducing this protein-protein
interaction.
So this molecule has an incredible ability to
potentially change the paradigm for
AR-positive breast cancer. So breast cancer is the most
common female cancer, accounting for greater than 300,000 new cases
per year in the United States. And HR-positive, HER2-negative
is the most common breast cancer subtype.
There's a lot of activity in this space.
To date, clinical activity of the next-gen SERDs, PROTACs, SARMs have
been really limited to the ESR1 mutant population.
Maybe hitting some portions of the wild type, but still not having the
profound effect as was hoped. And so what we're looking
for with this ER RIPTAC is that we have the potential to
be active, not only in the ESR1 mutant population, but also in the
ESR1 wild-type population.
Again, because this modality only requires full-length ER to be present, and
it does not need ER to be the tumor driver, because again, we're going to be
driving that cell killing through the loss of function of BRD4.
So you'll see a lot of the same types of assays across this program as I
showed you for the 915 program. 117 shows
very potent ternary complex formation. You can see here on the left.
In this program, you also see that we made stereochemical
controls with an ER-dead and a BRD4-dead molecule.
When you see both do not form a ternary complex as expected.
This molecule also shows very nice positive cooperativity, and you can
see that it has enhanced binding to BRD4 in the presence of ER
with an alpha value of greater than 10.
And this translates into that potent and selective activity in
ER-expressing cells. So on the right-hand side, we have TRex dox-inducible
lines for ER wild type.
And this is a nice representation of an ER-independent model.
It's an isogenic engineered system, but nonetheless, an interesting
one to think about. And you can see that we have potent activity when ER is
expressed and very weak micromolar activity when ER is not
expressed.
We move this compound in vivo. This is an MCF7
CDX model. It is an endocrine-sensitive setting, so keep that in mind.
You see on the left-hand side a nice dose response in
activity with regressions as we increase the dose levels of
HLD0117. It's also superior to fulvestrant, which
is shown in red. And you can see on the right-hand side a waterfall
plot of the individual tumors, where as we increase the dose, we see
increasing regressions with dose level three having very profound
regressions across all mice.
We also wanted to show activity in ER-dependent and
ESR1 mutant disease.
So if you look on the left-hand side, this is a ternary complex assay.
It's similar to what I showed you for the AR program.
We were able to selectively express different ER point
mutations in a cell line background and look at the ternary complex
formation. And you see that all of these mutants are
equipotent to wild type in the sub-nanomolar range for ternary
complex. So really showing that we should have activity across these different
point mutations.In the middle panel, that's the in vitro data
for MCF7 parental lines. You can see as a GI50 of one nanomolar,
we selectively express the Y537S mutation, and
you can see it loses no activity. And then this translates
nicely into an in vivo model. So this is a PDX model.
It's an ST-41 model. It's a post CDK4/6
inhibitor, ER-dependent endocrine resistance setting, but it has that
ESR1 point mutation of the Y537S. And you can
see that HLD0117 shows very nice activity.
Again, superior to fulvestrant.
So with that, very excited to see how 0117 plays
out in the phase one, and hopefully I've convinced everyone in the audience, if you
weren't convinced already, that this is a transformational new modality.
Shows that we can continue to think about induced proximity
as being a small molecule approach to really be
transformational in human disease.
So this is a novel strategy, and the exciting thing, again, is that target
protein does not need to be a disease driver.
That it's really this tumor-specific or tissue-specific ternary complex
formation that results in the essential protein loss of function, resulting
in that broad, potent activity with a nice safety window.
915 continues to look very promising in prostate cancer trials.
It's now in phase two, and the phase one for 117
was just posted a couple of days ago on clinicaltrials.gov.
So very excited to get that clinical trial off the ground.
And we're continuing to build a pipeline across major tumor types.
Also exploring hypotheses beyond oncology.
And so it's incredibly exciting to be part of Johnson & Johnson with the
global resources and the ability to really continue to
develop this new modality across multiple programs.
So thank you, and happy to take any questions.
Hi.
Wonderful talk. So what are the
technological limitations, i.e.,
it almost seems
not quite like a magic wand, but a little bit.
So what are the
technological limitations? Let me give you a hypothetical scenario.
CDK1,
required for cell division in all cells.
A terrible drug target on its own because of myeloid
toxicity. Can you come up with a Rib-tag
that sequesters CDK1 in the
context of a very specific cancer, let's say, overexpresses
a cancer-specific protein, let's just say GFAP for glioma.
Is that possible? Or what are the technological constraints in the
chemistry for making something like that actually happen?
Yeah, no, it's a great question. This opens up tremendous space in
thinking about new targets. So we can think about targets with
expression really in mind and thinking about the right
essential protein to combine in a given context.
And also we have numerous chemistry tools in our toolbox where we
don't need functional ligands. We can have silent binders so that we have less
off-target effects.
And in a specific context, there are some
nuances on what proteins can form protein-protein
interactions. They have to have compatible interfaces,
compatible
chemistries as far as where the different binding pockets line up
to form those PPIs.
Very excited about leveraging AI tools in this space.
I think that will really help us accelerate and prioritize some of these
different pairs that we want to begin to look at for new programs.
But I don't think anything's off the table.
I think that we really can, as long as we have that
selective expression, we can leverage just an
incredibly large toolbox in thinking about protein abundance,
localization, ligand ability, PPI
ability. So would those two work? I don't know.
We'll have to see experimentally whether or not those two would work.
And when we think about a new target at the outset, we
do
screening sets looking at multiple essential proteins that we believe will be
compatible to give us the best chance of success of identifying hits.
Okay, we got a lot of people lined up here, so we got to keep the
questions and answers
abbreviated. And we're going over here to this side now.
Hi. Jamie Christensen.
915, 100 migs dose for patients. It seems
silly to ask about a hook effect, but preponderance of the evidence, if
you look at everything, PD markers, preclinical data or otherwise, do
you see evidence of that?
Yeah, no, that's a great question, so I'll keep my answer short.
These molecules tend to not show hook effects, especially once they're
highly optimized, the positive cooperativity, the very slow
dissociation rates, that you can't outcompete the ternary complex.
It's actually more of a thermodynamic sink.
So we never saw that preclinically.
When you're referring to the 100-milligram dose, you're absolutely correct.
It's very few patients. We also presented at the Triple Meeting that we
didn't have a dose-dependent increase in exposure up at 100 milligrams.
So it could just be limitations of exposure of the compound at that dose.
Thanks.
Right side now.
Yep.
Hi, Katharine.
Hi over here.
Really impressive work, and it's rare for a new
modality to have such great monotherapy activity. It's really impressive.
My question is the way that the ADC field is being driven
by exploring novel payloads and seeing how that changes the
pharmacology of an ADC. Do you think that swapping out essential
proteins beyond BRD4 would be able to differentiate from what you already have in
the clinic?
Yeah, it's certainly possible. For the AR program, we
looked at a number of different essential proteins, and it actually pairs with
numerous ones. We loved the BRD4 profile, and we're able to
progress that very quickly into the clinic.
But
I think we're just scratching the surface of what we can do.
And I view the essential protein as another tool that we can think
about as a systems biology
within the context of the tumor. I think there's a lot of flexibility there.
So, time will tell, but I think it's definitely more broadly
applicable than just BRD4.
Over here.
Hey, Katherine. Congratulations, and good for the patients.
So my question is, how non-toxic do you think the
TP needs to be for your RibTac to maintain a
reasonable therapeutic margin? Thanks.
Yeah. It's a little hard to put a quantitative number to that.
But, I can say pre-clinically, we had excellent safety margins that
allowed us to start at an efficacious dose.
So, always the
bigger window you have, the better, and the more optimistic you feel moving
into patients that you're going to have a safe drug and be able to get to those
efficacious exposures.
But yeah,
I think you want to dial it out as much as possible.
It does not need to be a silent ligand.
But you can model these things pre-clinically to ensure that
where you think you'll be efficacious with your ternary complex modality, that
that's quite far away from that binary activity that you have for your essential
protein.
Thank you.
Over here.
Hi. Very excellent work. I have a question to
follow the selectivity.
The beginning of the data demonstrated that
L915 have a good selectivity
against the tumor cells and the normal cells.
But from the clinical data, we noticed that
the
hematoxicity and the
hepatotoxicity increased compared to the
AR protect. Do you think this
toxicity was due to the
inhibition of the BRD4?
Let me just try to summarize your question so I can answer it
correctly. So are you referring to the
safety profile versus protacs in the clinic?
Yes.
Is that your question?
Yes. If you compare your safety profiles to
the AR protect,
we will notice that the hematoxicity and hepatotoxicity
also increased. Do you think they
were due to the inhibition of the BRD4?
Oh, the toxicity seen.
The toxicity profile seen are very minimal.
It's generally Grade 1 fatigue.
We don't see the
thrombocytopenia or any of the effects of traditional BRD4 inhibitors.
So, I think the molecule has an excellent safety window.
I don't know if the data is mature enough to compare it to the
protac.
Thank you.
Thank you for the great talk. I was wondering about subcellular
localization of these RibTacs. So could you share
how these two RibTacs affect subcellular
localization of two EP and TP pairs?
Yeah. No, thanks. We published a chemical biology proof of concept
paper that showed some of the co-localization
experiments, and we've seen that play out as we move into
bona fide targets.
If you've co-localization, you have the best
chance to interact with your proteins.
Now, if they're in different cellular compartments, as long as they have the
opportunity to interact, I think they can make successful protein partners.
It's well known that in advanced prostate cancer, that the majority of
AR is in the nucleus, and BRD4 is a nuclear protein.
So, you can conclude that it's primarily
a nuclear ternary complex.
So which,
AR recruits BRD4 or BRD4 recruits AR to its
position?
Well, it has very strong binding to AR and weak binding to BRD4.
So
most likely the sequence of events is binding to AR and then BRD4.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Over there.
If you were to strip the linker and just do a preclinical study where you had an
enzalutamide plus a BET inhibitor in those AR models,
like the LNcap, do you think you get the same anti-tumor activity, or do you
think it's more a complex?
No. We've done those experiments.
We
had to spend a long time convincing ourselves at the beginning, right, that it
wasn't just a combinatorial effect, that it truly was
this ternary complex-driven pharmacology.
In most
prostate cancer cell lines, BRD4 is cytostatic.
And even in combination, you don't really see that apoptotic phenotype.
But you see that with the AR BRD4 RibTac.
So,
we've generated a host of data to show that it's definitely
significantly different than just a combination play.
Thank you.
I think we have to take just two more questions so we didn't run too
late. And then I'm sure Kat will be happy to answer after the session.
But over here.
Hi.
For your target selection, for the pair of the targets
to select, how important is it to factor in
the relative protein abundance? I'm just curious.
How important is it to what? The relative protein abundance.
Protein abundance. Essential protein versus the- Yeah. No, that's a great question.
You can think about essential proteins as,
they've been well-studied, right?
What percentage of knockdown
is needed for a cell-killing effect? That's going to vary by protein.
And so you just have to look at the relative abundance and your ability to
sequester your essential protein to have the apoptotic or
cell-killing effect that's desired.
So it's going to vary by context, but certainly, it's applicable to low
abundance proteins. It's just all about the selection of the protein partners at
that point
And last question over here.
Maybe this is a good follow-on for that, but can you comment on the criteria
that you prioritize when pairing an essential protein with a
cancer-specific protein?
So in selecting the protein partners?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
So definitely we think a lot about expression
and the disease-relevant tissues to expression and healthy
tissues. Think about localization,
PPI ability assessment. You have to also be able to think about can
you make a molecule that you could effectively dose a human
with the different binding pockets and how they're accessible
to the protein partners. So there's quite a bit of analysis that goes
into that pairing algorithm.
Thank you.
Yeah, thanks.
All right. Thank you, Cat. Great talk.
Okay. I'm going to round out the session here and hopefully get us
back on time. Thanks for all the discussion on
the Rip-Tag program. So I'm Ryan Potts.
I'm here representing Amgen and our
induced proximity and small molecule therapy discovery teams, telling you a
little bit about how we think about the opportunity for induced
proximity in the context of targeted protein
degradation. And I'll go through a few examples of how we're
leveraging this type of technology and hopefully give you
a flavor of the opportunities and the options
to do so.
Hopefully, now that we're sort of at the very end of the day of
this session and this
chemistry to clinic
four-part series, you already know all about induced proximity and
how one can leverage this in many different ways to
control proteins and
control biology for therapeutic modulation.
And I'm going to talk to you at first about how we like
to destroy proteins through targeted protein degradation,
where we induce the proximity to
E3 ubiquitin ligase to a target, either through the use of heterobifunctional
molecules as depicted on this slide, or
are more interesting at areas around the use of
monovalent molecules or as we oftentimes refer to them as
molecular glues.
To do so, we need ability to bind to E3 ubiquitin
ligases in the cell. There's probably
close to 600 different ubiquitin ligases in humans.
However, in the past, it's been relatively challenging to get chemical matter to
these ligases, therefore limiting potentially the target space
and the therapeutic opportunities for this modality.
So several years ago, when we set out in our
induced proximity platform,
we said we need to enable more ligases, which will enable more
target space.
And I'm happy to report that over the years, we've now enabled
over 35 different ligases with highly
qualified chemical matter encompassing over 350
different ligands. And that enables us to access more
ligases and more potential target space.
And we like to then take those molecules, and of course, we can make things like
PROTACs, bifunctional molecules, but we're more interested in potential molecular
glues.
Mostly because with the molecular glues, as you sort of just
maybe heard about before, they generally do not require a
drug binding site or pocket on the target protein.
With many of these opportunities induced proximity, you hear about
needing a ligand to the target and needing a ligand to the effector.
Well, that limits the potential optionality.
And so molecular glues usually take advantage of
protein-protein interface interactions such that the
molecule likely only binds to one side of this
ternary complex, in this case, the ubiquitin ligase, and will have
essentially non-measurable affinity to the target.
Of course, these molecules also are more drug-like and
thus are easier to potentially develop.
However, the challenge has been how to discover glue
molecules. In the past, they've been largely discovered
serendipitously and retrospectively understood to work through this mechanism.
And so we've been
setting out to understand how to do this more effectively.
And I'll tell you a little bit of how we've been doing this using this
toolbox of over 350 different ligands that are all
starting points for molecular glues.
And as I mentioned, finding these molecular glues has typically in the past been
thought of as sort of finding a needle in the haystack.
And so our solution really is just to build a haystack that only has
needles in it. Take all of those ligands that we have and diversify those
ligands such as here is a prototypical example
of
a VHO binding molecule. It typically has this
hydroxyproline motif. And then we can narrow that down to sort of the
minimal pharmacophore, and then identify the sites on that molecule
where we can diversify and build chemical libraries that have
moderate affinity to ligase.
But then is essentially blanketing the surface of this
E3 ligase, inducing new opportunities for it to interact with
things that maybe it didn't interact in the past or interacted with
weakly.
And through doing this, we can take those
ligase molecules that I told you about before and build those kinds of
libraries to them. And now we have here described
aMore than half a million
molecular glue
library encompassing several different
ubiquitin ligases, as illustrated here, enables us
to screen in various different ways, including target-centric as well as
target-agnostic approaches that I'll describe.
So by growing this number of different ubiquitin ligases that were
enabled and diversifying the chemistry into these types of
libraries I just described,
and we can screen these across many different cell lineages, it really
enables us to broaden the target space
to identify the best therapeutic opportunities and
achieve the sort of mission that we've put,
that is to be able to drug any target every time.
So here, let me give you an example of what we can do with these kinds
of libraries. So here's an example where we
took a VHL ubiquitin ligase molecular glue
library,
that I sort of discussed before,
and screened that molecule through those sets of
molecules through high-throughput proteomics, where we can run tens of
thousands of samples to profile against the entire
proteome, what are they modulating the expression levels of?
And here is an example of one of those molecules.
It is a binder to the VHL ubiquitin ligase.
It has a hydroxyproline motif.
And when we profile this in proteomics, you can see that it only calls the
degradation of one protein up there in the top left, and that is
caspase-2, previously an undrugged or a
protein that hasn't been degraded before.
We can confirm this is our own mechanism activity, where we can
see robust degradation of caspase-2,
here measured by a Hi-BIT assay, and we can show that's proteasome
and VHL dependent.
And then confirming the molecular glue nature of this molecule, we can purify
these proteins, in this case, VHL and caspase-2, and show robust
ternary complex formation consistent with the molecular glue
not showing any kind of hook effect.
Through a number of additional studies that I won't have time to go through today,
sort of summarized in this
model of the ternary complex, where you see that the molecule is
sitting at the interface between the CARD domain, a previously
undrugged
domain, and the interface of caspase-2, that is then
bridging to the VHL binding site.
Now, that is
one example of how we can leverage these new ligases
to drug proteins that previously we haven't been able to get through
traditional ligase, such as cereblon.
But in this case, we relied on proteomics as a screening
platform, which has its limitations in terms of how
high a throughput it can be. And so we said, "Can we come up with other or
additional ways to screen beyond proteomics to get at
these huge number of molecular glue libraries that we have?"
And so we partnered with
a biotech here in the San Diego area, Plexxium, to deploy this
very interesting technology to be able to
synthesize molecular glue libraries that I just described on
beads in a bar-coded way. So this is a DNA-encoded
library that is
synthesized on beads, such that the
beads are carrying the molecular glue molecules in addition to a DNA
barcode that tells you the identity of each molecule.
And the key is that we wanted to screen, not for protein
degradation, but for a more generic endpoint that we could screen
in higher throughput in a target-agnostic way.
The concept that many of the targets that we're interested in are
things like transcription factors and other types of gene expression controls,
will ultimately lead to alterations in gene expression
patterns. And so if we could set up a high-throughput way to
screen these molecules
for alteration of gene expression, we could do that and help
understand and triage molecules to identify interesting hits.
So using this bar-coded DNA
library on beads, we could deploy this into a
picowell setting, where we have a small number of cells incubated with
beads, each bead with a different molecule,
use UV
photo-mediated release of the molecule from the
beads,
allowing it to go into cells and alter the biology in whatever way it does.
And then the trick is that we could then recapture the
RNA from these cells on that same bead that
carries the identity of the molecule that was there based on
the DNA-encoded library tag. And then use next-generation
sequencing to do this on a scalable approach.
In this case, we profiled 25,000 different molecules
for how they alter gene expression.
And coming out of that came this one molecule, for example, from our
VHL library, that we refer to here as dGem3, where you can
again see that sort of central hydroxyproline motif, but now it's altered
on the left and right side relative to that molecule I showed you in the past.
And you can see here by looking at the transcriptomic, this is not the
proteome, this is a transcriptome analysis, that this
molecule is altering the expression of a number of different
genes.
That's in comparison to, for example, a high-affinity
VHL binding molecule that we refer to here as the dGem
negative molecule.
And on the right side, you can see the transcriptomics gene expression profile is
not altered at all.
Now, once we found that molecule, we of course wanted to know why was it causing
gene expression alterations. And one way we could do that is we
tagged the VHL protein in those cells
with a biotin ligase motif.So that when we add
our molecule, we can look for new proteins that were induced in proximity
to the VHL ubiquitin ligase and identify those through pull down and mass
spectrometry. And so what you can see in this plot is that
essentially all of the proteins that were induced into be in
proximity to VHL by the molecule,
are part of this SMN, survival motor neuron,
complex that is involved in mRNA splicing.
Through then use of proteomics, we could identify which specific protein
is modulating the expression, and it turns out that only a single protein
is modulated by this molecule, and it is one of those
components of that SMN complex called Gemin3,
as shown here in this proteomics volcano plot.
This is strictly dependent on VHL.
If you knock out VHL, you see no alteration
of Gemin3 levels. And we can again purify
the complex proteins, here Gemin3 and
VHL, and show by SPR a ternary complex
at a KD of around 70 nanomolar.
So this,
through structural studies and other
studies that I won't have time to go into, we can map down the
specific domain on Gemin3 is the ATP binding
domain within the helicase function of the Gemin3 that forms this
ternary complex to the VHL E3 ubiquitin
ligase. These two examples hopefully show you
that we can go much further beyond the
cereblon
ubiquitin ligase space for discovery of molecular glues, which has
largely been only the focus,
in this case, showing you two examples of VHL, but we have
several others even beyond the VHL ubiquitin ligase.
Now, that is really educating us on how to
find molecular glues.
But unfortunately, things like Gemin3 are not
therapeutically interesting,
largely because it's required in all cells, and
there's going to be no therapeutic window.
And so,
this is not going to be of interest unless we had some way to specifically
degrade Gemin3 only in,
for example, a cancer cell. And so we started thinking about
could we come up with some type of cancer specific ubiquitin
ligase,
that we could do this same kind of approach or use a PROTAC to
allow us to then potentially
even degrade these pan-essential proteins.
And we came up with this concept that
actually a lot of viruses and many of these viruses being oncogenic,
like HPV, human papillomavirus,
encode viral proteins
that indeed are E3 ubiquitin ligases.
They co-opt the host or the human ubiquitin
ligase system to reprogram cells through
inducing degradation of various factors.
For example, say p53 in the case of
the HPV
E6 viral ubiquitin ligase.
And so we said maybe there's an opportunity that if we could come
up with molecules that engage these viral E3
ligases,
we could actually then use those and repurpose them to actually degrade
pan-essential things like
that
Gemin3 that I mentioned before. And so we refer to this concept
as
VIPER-TACs or viral E3 pan-essential removing
targeting chimera.
So first we wanted to show that indeed, that if you could,
in a
chemical genetics approach, reprogram these viral ubiquitin ligases,
could you actually degrade things?
And so we tested a number of these viral ligases and showed that
indeed, that you could get degradation of different proteins, which was
encouraging. And so we focused in on this E6 viral
ligase protein, given the
opportunity potentially to impact HPV positive
cancers.
So then what about on the essential side?
Well, we took the DepMap data, which of course has been profiled
over a thousand different cancer cell lines to see what was
essential and
identified a number of pan-essential proteins and
honed in on this one in particular, SARS-1, a serine
aminoacyl tRNA transferase that's required for, of course, protein
translation.
And we showed that the E6 viral ubiquitin ligase
protein, when induced in proximity to
SARS-1, could show robust degradation,
and could be rescued by various controls
like the proteasome inhibitor, et cetera.
So now with that concept, we took it into cells
that were either HPV positive or HPV negative, and
measured to see whether indeed we would get specific
cell killing of HPV positive versus HPV negative.
And that's indeed what you can see here in the red line being the HPV positive.
You can see robust cell killing of a tool molecule that induces
degradation of SARS-1 compared to the HPV negative.
We liken this to in the HPV neg, and
the viper is just sitting quiescent, not doing anything
until the HPV viral protein comes along.
Okay.
So then to round things out,
I want to make sure we don't leave without thinking about alternate
degradation mechanisms beyond the ubiquitin and proteasome system.
And of course, on the right side of this slideAs you'll know,
the sort of cellular trash can is the lysosome,
an organelle that is prevalent in all our cells and actually upregulated in many
types of cancer. And so we thought about how we
might leverage this mechanism to degrade other proteins
like, for example,
membrane-associated proteins that can be modulated very easily through the
lysosome.
And so
we had a really interesting idea of how to do that,
because lysosomes actually have a number of
proteins
that reside at their membrane and refer to lysosomal membrane
proteins. And these proteins, some of them can
be rapidly turned over through a process that is
ubiquitin and escort machinery-dependent microautophagy,
such that they're turning over on the
very rapid timescale. As illustrated here, for one example,
Rnf152 is a lysosomal membrane protein
that when you block
protein synthesis with cycloheximide, as shown in this blot at the bottom left,
you can see that within four hours, the protein is completely wiped out.
And so this led to the concept that maybe we could
piggyback on this constant
turnover of these proteins by the lysosome
through these
lysosomal membrane targeting chimeras or LIMTACS, bifunctional
molecules that would recruit
things to the lysosomal membrane that typically aren't there and are dragged
into the lysosome through this LIMTAC
mechanism. And so as a proof of concept, we started with
one of our favorite
oncogenes, KRAS G12D, to see if we can
indeed do this. Of course, KRAS is not residing at the
lysosome typically.
And so this is illustrated here that indeed this works.
So you're seeing here in the top row of images,
you're looking at in the control case, so DMSO treated, you can see
that on the top left image, KRAS is at the plasma membrane, sort
of outlining the cell surface.
Rnf152 overlaps with the lysosomal marker Lamp1.
It's hanging out at lysosomes, and they're not together.
However, when you add this tool molecule, this LIMTAC,
recruits KRAS from the plasma membrane to the
lysosome membrane through interactions with
Rnf152.
And this
ultimately results in degradation of KRAS
G12D and inhibition of downstream
signaling as evidenced through phospho-ERK
here.
So we said this is quite interesting. It's a very different type of pharmacology.
You actually have two things happening.
You have relocalization. You're changing the
localization of KRAS from the plasma
membrane, where it needs to be present to be active to activate
RAF and downstream MAP kinase signaling.
You're moving it away from there to the lysosomal membrane,
and you're turning over the protein at the same time.
So we thought maybe that pharmacology actually could give you advantage.
It may lead to more sustained
inhibition of KRAS signaling even when you wash out the
molecule. And that's what's shown in this slide here.
When you use a KRAS inhibitor,
of course you get rapid, robust inhibition, but when you wash out that molecule,
phospho-ERK comes back quite quickly.
However, when we use this LIMTAC mechanism in this third
column of treatment, you can see sustained degradation of
KRAS and sustained inhibition of phospho-ERK.
And this translates into a more robust cell
killing as evidenced in this
cell viability assay with the LIMTAC molecule in the red.
So hopefully
what you've heard from me today, but more importantly
from a number of speakers today, is that
we need continued innovation in drug discovery.
The low-hanging fruits are gone. We're now only
reaching high into the tree, and we believe that
this concept of proximity-based therapeutics
is really going to be the ladders to get us to those high-hanging fruits.
And this is allowing us to take on these challenging targets through a
number of different mechanisms. You've heard about different types of
degrader modalities that I talked a little bit about and Dan talked about,
as well as other speakers earlier today.
But this plethora of new non-degrader mechanisms that you
heard from Kat and many other speakers throughout the day that just
allow us to be very creative
at how we go about doing drug discovery.
And so I'm very excited to see where the future takes
us.
So I'll stop there. Thank many of the people that did the work that are
listed on this slide. And if there are any questions, I'd
be happy to take them.
Hi there.
With the Viper tags, you said it was E6 mediated,
but is it E6AP, the actual-
Yeah
... E3 ligase that's inducing the degradation?
Yeah. Great question. I didn't show the data, but
you're right. So the HPV encoded protein
E6Is essentially like
a super large molecular glue. It is a protein that binds
to a
human genome-encoded ubiquitin ligase called
E6AP or E6-associated protein.
And I didn't show you the data, but all of the degradation that we're
seeing with our E6-directed
ViperTags are E6AP-dependent.
Yep. Okay. Thank you.
Yes. You're welcome.
Yep.
So again, a question about the E6
protein targeting here.
When you think about it, viruses always have
ways of evolving and evading
any challenge by the host, and so you have to
wonder whether this is a risk here.
And
specifically, of course, the risk would be high
if, for some reason, HPV would be able to
retain oncogenic functions of E6, but maybe
mutate the binding site for these
ViperTags. So my question is, what do you
know about that binding site and the binding
surface? Is that identical or overlapping
with the binding surface that the E6 protein uses
for its oncogenic protein interactions?
Yeah. It's a great question, and I think the key
is going forward is you're going to have to identify, as you're alluding to,
the ideal scenario is portions of the molecule
interacting with these viral proteins
that
are going to be essential for the activity of
the oncogenic activity, and therefore are hard to mutate
away from.
In this case, we're just using a tool molecule, so
that's really not applicable in this case, but I think that is what the desired
scenario is.
I'm not sure if there's any
great ligands for E6 out there right now, and so I think that will be a
challenge
for the field to try to ligand this in a way.
Again, you have to keep
its ability to bind to the E6AP protein to be active.
Thanks for the question.
Hi. Nice talk. So was
E6AP always expressed? Usually, the virus infects
cells that could be silenced.
Yeah.
Yeah. No question. You have to consider that
you'll need the E6 protein present to be active of
these kinds of molecules. I agree.
Yeah, usually. But the virus sometimes
offer, in fact, the cancer cells, it could get the mutation
on the DNA, and then these virus proteins don't express.
They're really heterogeneous
in the cancer cells, the expression of these virus proteins.
Yeah, I think that would be a selection criteria is you would need the
expression of the E6 protein in this case.
Okay.
Yeah.
Thank you for your talk. Very nice work.
I wanted to go back to one of your early slides where you showed the 350
molecule toolbox for the 35 new E3 ligases, and I
wonder what you can share about what you found out about those E3 ligases,
the ligand's ability to use them in TBD.
Yeah, it's a good question.
These were not necessarily chosen at random.
We really think about what types of ligases might be best
suitable for
this type of activity.
Obviously, ligand ability is a key criteria but not the only
criteria.
We oftentimes have profiled
hundreds of ubiquitin ligases in
assays, for example, to see whether we induce them in proximity with
tool molecules, will it actually be competent to degrade
many different targets, or is it
not active, or maybe it's super selective.
That can dictate ligases that we're interested in.
We think about those
ligases that maybe have
surfaces that are more moldable or plastic that maybe are
quite critical criteria for
molecular glues because we know they rely heavily on protein-protein interface
interactions to be active.
We think about expression profiles.
Sometimes we want ligases that are very ubiquitous.
Other times, we might want ligases that are only expressed in
some type of specific cell type or disease state, depending on the
therapeutic hypothesis. So I think there's a lot of
different criteria that go into the selection,
and it's a really key
point that we spend a lot of time on before embarking
on a ligand discovery campaign.
Thank you.
Okay, I think we've come to the bitter end.
Thank you all for staying, and hope you have a good rest of the day.
Great job.